Angela Bassett
just won a best supporting actress at
the Golden Globes you didn't catch the
broadcast okay me neither but I saw the
clip and I really really loved this clip
because Angela bassett's speech was a
real example of a Class Act okay and she
addressed this topic as we're talking
now about how some people are clamoring
for reparations to the tune of five
million dollars because they're ten
times great grandfather was a slave or
something Angela Bassett instead of
focusing on resentment as so many people
do now at award ceremonies in particular
on the sports fields in public life
Angela Bassett focused on the opposite
gratitude in order for that Destiny to
manifest I think that it requires
courage to have faith
it requires patience
as we just heard and it requires a true
sense of yourself it's not easy because
the path is circuitous and it has many
unexpected detours but by the grace of
God I stand here I stand Here grateful
grateful grateful to the Hollywood
Foreign Press for giving me this honor
along with wakanda forever grateful to
my amazing team who every day each and
every one of them work work along with
me and beside me and on my behalf each
and every day grateful to my family
Courtney B Vance Bronwyn and Slater I
love you from the depths of my heart and
my mother always said that good things
come to those who pray and I see the
truth of that every day
love it what a Class Act I want to put
that part of the speech on repeat I want
to play it in every classroom in America
that's so right not only is it a classy
thing to say add it in a word ceremony
as you're being handed a trophy but it's
just the right attitude to have in life
you can approach life anybody anybody
can approach life from the perspective
of resentment and anxiety and Dread and
fear and general irritation
or any person can approach life from the
perspective of gratitude and the reason
for that is you are not responsible for
the creation of your life you did not
make yourself you did not will yourself
into the world your life is a gift so
every single thing that you get
is a gift from God and you don't deserve
it you didn't earn it that's just a gift
that you were given freely and you owe a
gratitude for that exactly the right way
and she ends it on that note she doesn't
just talk about gratitude out in The
Ether this kind of new age you know it's
the it's the Vibes and the energy man
you know and The Echoes and the ripples
no she's saying it's good to pray
not just send Good Vibes but pray good
things come to those who pray
maybe not Material good things and
plenty of God's favorite people have
suffered enormously
but ultimately good things come to those
who pray
because prayer is conducive to happiness
gratitude is conducive to happiness
that's why the do batters who are
destroying our society are are trying to
get people to stop praying in fact this
just happened over at the Mall of
America that gigantic Mall in
Minneapolis a guy was wearing a t-shirt
said Jesus saves
really simple t-shirt
very basic statement that people have
been wearing on their bodies and their
clothing for 2000 years now you probably
could have found Romans and togas
wearing the phrase Jesus saves and the
authorities probably wouldn't have liked
that either this guy gets harassed
and told to leave by a mall cop for
wearing that offensive statement
associated with religion
[Music]
okay but it's the same thing okay people
have been offended and like I said all
we were asking you is to take your shirt
off you go to Macy's
I didn't say anything
if you want to shop here you need to
take that shirt off it is religious
soliciting there is no soliciting
allowed on all property which is private
property
and they just keep harassing this guy
the clip goes on and on and on the cop
Won't Back Down the guy says I didn't
even say anything
I'm just wearing this shirt and it says
Jesus saves it's not an obscene shirt in
fact if it were an obscene shirt I'm
sure the cops wouldn't have hassled him
but because he's wearing a shirt that
makes a statement that is good and true
and beautiful and conducive to happiness
and human flourishing that's why the
powers that be are after him and this
should come as no surprise
the devil is the prince of this world
okay this is nothing new we like to
Lament The Lizard people over in Davos
because of because they're awful they're
awful and they want to destroy our lives
I'm not downplaying that but this is not
a new thing okay we fight against
principalities and powers and evil and
wickedness in the very high places okay
and all the way down to the very lowest
echelons of that Authority and
enforcement all the way down to this
mall cop trying to shuffle a Christian
out there because what he was wearing on
his shirt the cop considered to be
offensive in a way it is offensive
it's offensive in a very wonderful way
it's offending the the
evil sensibilities of a fallen world but
it is offensive it's making an exclusive
claim it's saying that if you want to be
saved you're saved through God the son
that's how you're saved
what if people say well what but I but I
don't want to worship Jesus okay well
you know that's
I guess that's a you problem I imagine
that's what this man would say he's
wearing a shirt that says Jesus saves
well why can't God save Mankind in some
other way that I would prefer that's
what all sorts of people have been
asking for the last 2000 years why can't
why can't the religion of me be true
whatever my preferred version is how
dare you suggest that your vision is
true I'm going to punish you for doing
that
yeah of course look what they did to
Jesus okay of course they're hustling
this guy out of the Mall of America it
is offensive
but
the shirt is true okay a story I really
wanted to get to on Monday I'm glad we
have like a minute or so to get to it
now
Lisa Marie Presley died Lisa Marie
Presley was the only daughter of Elvis
Presley only child of Elvis Presley she
was only 54 years old some of you may
know I don't know I haven't been totally
open about this on the show
I am a huge Elvis fan I am a die-hard
Elvis fan I've been a huge Elvis fan
since I was five years old I was
pictured in my local newspaper doing a
little Elvis song and dance when I was
in kindergarten I would on occasion do
an Elvis impersonation as part of a
variety show in Hawaii I I just I've got
Elvis memorabilia I've I once visited
The West Wing
for the first time and Graceland for the
first time within a relatively short
period of time I was much more in awe of
Graceland okay I'm just a huge
Elvis fan
very very sad that Lisa Marie Presley
died some people are blaming on the
vaccine I don't think there's evidence
of that I mean I wouldn't be surprised I
just I don't see any evidence of that
obviously there were heart problems in
in Elvis's family his mother had heart
problems he had heart problems at least
Marie had heart problems it would seem
uh the the Presleys had been pretty open
about their drug problems over the years
uh poor Lisa Marie's son who looked just
like his grandfather died a couple of
years ago so had a hard life the reason
I bring it up at all is one you know
good to pray for the Presleys are really
near and dear to my heart even though
I've never met any of them but also
to make a point that is really important
to to keep in mind especially as we talk
about the rulers of the world the rich
hobnobbing over in Davos with their
private jets and their champagne and all
the rest of it
it's a it's a warning story from Lisa
Marie Presley
Lisa Marie Presley has been Rich every
day of her life
material prosperity
does not determine a happy life
and when I say that everyone's going to
say duh yeah Michael tell me something I
don't know wow what what genius Insight
over here from the philosopher Mr
Michael money doesn't buy happiness I
know I know everybody knows that
except we all forget it we all forget it
all the time
we say oh if I just had a little bit
more money then I'd be happy look at the
people in Davos are those people happy
I don't I don't know they don't seem
like happy people to me Bill Gates
doesn't seem like a happy person to me
the the philosophers of Davos who go on
stage and say God is fake news there is
no soul we are nothing all the little
people we're going to apply them with
drugs and video games they're useless
people they're like we're gonna feed
them crickets and let oh they're sucking
up the air polluting my world oh these
those don't the people who are saying
that don't seem like very happy people
to me
you look at Hollywood you look at the
Rich and Famous
you look at their lives are so
disordered so much of the time and then
you think about the happiest people you
know
poor people have plenty of problems too
but seems to me that
there are very very poor people who are
happy and very very poor people who are
unhappy and the same is true for rich
people which means that the determinant
for happiness is not money the
Communists are wrong the determinant for
happiness is not how much money you have
even the kind of liberal technocrats are
wrong the the determinant for happiness
is not how much money you have the greed
is good hardcore
Wall Street 1980s Republicans let's all
get rich
kind of right winger types their premise
is wrong too
it's not to say that money is a bad
thing
money can can be a lovely thing it's not
that the root of money is that money
rather is the root of all evil that's
not true people misquote that quite a
lot the love of money is the root of all
evil
but money itself is the money itself is
just material and your life does not
hinge on material things
because contrary to what all these
Geniuses who think they know so much
better than you who think that they can
upend the whole world and run your life
for you all these Geniuses who are
virtually all materialists of One sort
or another
contrary to what they believe you are
more than just your body and you're more
than just your stuff and if you if you
treat yourself like you're just a hunk
of meat to be manipulated by various
chemicals and things that money can buy
you are not going to live a happy life
you're going to be just as happy as
those lizard people over in Switzerland
[Music]
thank you